Okay, so now we're going to go over to
Christopher Quill. Chris is now going to
show you on the computer how you calculate
your distributions for initially the S&P
500, but you can use this for any asset.
So take it away, Chris.
So in this example, we're going to look at
a day trading strategy for the S&P 500
over a period of roughly 50 years. By
calculating these daily returns, we should
get a good idea of how the S&P 500
the underlying asset behaves behaves on a
daily basis. So we're going to start by
going to Yahoo Finance and obtaining the
data. So finance.yahoo.com. And then in
the ticker box, we type S&P and we select
the first drop down item, S&P 500. And
this gives us a summary phrase
page of the S&P 500 with Yahoo Finance's
last available price for the asset. But
we're going to go to historical prices on
the left hand side and update the
historical price table by editing the
inputs given at the top here. So we're
looking for data from between the 3rd of
January 1962 to the 9th of November 2012
on a daily frequency.
So once we've set our parameters, we
update the table by clicking Get Prices
and we scroll to the bottom of the page
and click Download to Spreadsheet.
At this stage, you can select to save the
spreadsheet to your hard drive. Or as
we're going to do, you can just open the
spreadsheet straight away and save it once
it's open.
With the spreadsheet open, we're just
going to go to File, Save As. We're going
to save it as S&P 500 Returns
Distribution.
And we'll save it as an Excel workbook.
And I'm going to save it on my desktop so
it's easy to find.
So the first thing that we're going to do
is adjust this date column so we can see
the dates.
So we just click on the column
intersection and adjust the width of the
column like that by clicking and dragging.
So this is all the price data for the S&P
500 from the daily price data from the
period that we've selected.
So in our example, we're only going to use
the open and closing prices to calculate
daily returns.
So let's go ahead and do that by heading
up column H with returns in cell H1.
And then in H2, type our returns formula,
which is brackets, closing price for that
day minus the opening price for that day,
divided by the opening price, which gets
it in terms of a percentage return for
that day.
And then we want to apply the formula that
we've just put into cell H2 down the whole
returns column.
So a quick way to do that is click
anywhere in the data from column A to G.
So cell G2, for example, and press CTRL
and down to navigate quickly to the bottom
of the spreadsheet.
And then find the last cell in column H.
So that is H12804.
And then we press CTRL, shift and up to
quickly select all the return cells that
we want to implement our formula into.
And then with that selected, we just press
CTRL, D to copy that formula down from
cell H2 to the rest of the column.
So now we've got our returns, we want to
be able to analyse them and interpret them
in terms of a distribution.
So by that I mean we want to be able to
understand how many of these daily
returns, S&P 500 daily returns,
lie within specific ranges that we set.
And we're going to set those ranges by
creating intervals in the data.
So in column J, cell J1, head up the
column with intervals.
Okay.
And then what we want to do is come up
with a reasonable set of intervals for
trading the S&P 500 daily.
So a lower bound for the ranges we're
interested in might be minus 2%, for
example, because we're only looking at
daily data.
So looking at anything with too wider
range would be pointless because it
wouldn't really show us the core of our
data set.
So we'll start with minus 2%, so minus
0.02, we enter into cell J2.
And then we'll go up in increments of half
a percent.
So in the next cell, J3, we type 0.0.015,
press enter.
And to quickly use this interval that
we've set and copy it down to an upper
bound of plus 2%,
we select those two cells, J2 and J3, and
then select the small black box in the
bottom right-hand corner of the selection
and drag it down to cell J10, which gives
us plus 0.02, which is plus 2%.
So we're going to use these intervals to
create a distribution table to see the
frequency of our daily returns that land
within these intervals.
So to do that, we have to go to data on
the ribbon and data analysis on the
right-hand side.
If you don't have this at this point,
there's a guide of how you obtain this
data analysis option in the accompanying
PDF.
And you do it by installing an add-in to
Excel called Analysis Toolpack.
So we go ahead and click on Data Analysis.
And we want to create a histogram data.
So that's basically a frequency table.
And press OK.
And we're going to create this table from
our returns data.
So we select in the input range, cell H2,
and press Ctrl-Shift and down to quickly
select that whole returns column.
The bin range is just the intervals that
we want to define our ranges with, that
we're interested in interpreting our
returns within.
So our bin range is just our intervals
that we created in column J, from J2,
Ctrl-Shift down, select to J10.
Now, we want to display this histogram
data in this spreadsheet that we're
working in, rather than a new worksheet.
So in output options, we select output
range, and you can see this throws you
back to the input range box, which we've
already filled in with our returns data.
So we need to be careful to click off that
into output range and select whereabouts
in the spreadsheet we want this frequency
table to be.
So we're going to use cell L2, and we're
going to use cell L2, and so we click L2
and press OK, and that gives us a tabular
format of a histogram.
So basically, a frequency table, and what
this essentially means is, if we take the
first row, for example, in this table,
this means that 285 days, the S&P 500
yields a return of less than or equal to
minus 2%.
And the next row, and the next row, 345
days, yields a return of between minus 2%
and minus 1.5%.
OK, and that's how the table works.
So if you go to the bottom, eventually you
get to 307 days, lie greater than 2%.
OK, so what would be useful is if we
interpreted this data visually, so we
create a graph from this data.
So to do that, we just select the data,
L3, click and drag to M12 to select that
data, and go to Insert on the ribbon,
Column, and the first 2D Column Chart
option.
Click that, and that gives us a histogram
of our data.
OK, so at the moment, what we can see is
that clearly more returns on our
distribution lie close to zero.
OK, so that's what we can tell so far, and
that a lot less, it sort of tails off, and
it looks something like a bell-shaped
curve, a bit like a, well, a lot like a
normal distribution at the moment,
where there's a lot less frequency of
returns, where there's a lot less
frequency of returns in the tails, than in
the centre.
OK, so we should tidy this graph up, and
make it a little bit more easy to
interpret.
I'm just going to go ahead and zoom out of
the spreadsheet a little bit.
To do that easily, you can just hold CTRL
and then use your mouse wheel to zoom in
and out of the spreadsheet.
So, we're going to replace this horizontal
x-axis with some more appropriate labels,
so we can understand the ranges that our
frequency of data lie within.
So, to do that, let's create a range
column in column N.
So, in N2, we'll type range.
And in N3, we'll type the appropriate
range that applies to this bin value, and
so on.
And we'll do that in all of these cells,
from N3 to N12.
Before we do that, though, because we're
going to type it in as text, we want to
format these cells, so they know that
these cells are going to be displayed as
text, or understood as text.
So, we select all those cells, and
right-click within the selection, and
click Format Cells.
And we then want to change the category to
text, and press OK.
Okay, so we'll start with the first row,
and we'll call this range less than minus
2%, and then the next range will be minus
2% to minus 1.5%, and so on.
So, we're just using the bin values as a
reference to complete this table, this
column, rather.
So, it's a little bit tedious, but it's a
good thing to do, so you can actually
understand your data graphically with the
correct ranges defined.
And in the last cell, in cell N12, we're
going to type greater than 2%.
Okay, and let's adjust this column width,
column N, so it can include all that text,
and it doesn't overlap into another
column.
Okay, so now we want to change the
horizontal axis labels to the ranges that
we've created here.
So, to do that, we click on the graph, and
right-click, and select data.
And then we want to change the horizontal
category axis label, and edit, so we click
on edit, and we change it from these bin
values, which are currently selected, to
these range values instead.
And we just press OK, and OK again, and
you can see that it's updated our
histogram, and now we can understand what
these bars actually mean, in terms of the
ranges that they apply to.
Okay, so the next thing we'll do is delete
this series label, so we just click on
series 1 and press delete, and I suppose
we want to add some axis labels to this
graph, so we can understand it even
better.
So, to do that, we go to chart tools
layout in the ribbon, and then axis
titles, and we'll label the primary
horizontal axis first.
We'll choose title below axis, and that
gives us axis title as the title, so we
want to select that, delete it, and
replace it with daily return range.
Click off it, and then the same thing to
the vertical axis title, we'll choose
rotated title, select it, and delete, and
we'll rename it as frequency.
Okay, so that's our histogram done, so we
can graphically see the frequency of daily
S&P returns that lie within these ranges
historically over the period that we've
considered.
Okay, so I've already talked about how
this distribution is much like a normal
bell-shaped curve, but for those of you a
little bit more familiar with the normal
distribution,
we can see that these bars don't tail off
quite as quickly as a normal distribution
would.
Basically meaning the tails are slightly
fatter, that we can see visually, meaning
there's more extreme values, and we'll
come on, we'll sort of prove that in our
data as we continue, but we can already
see that this isn't quite a normal
distribution.
So, we can use Excel to give us some
summary statistics of our data set, and to
do that we go to data, and data analysis,
then we're going to choose descriptive
statistics, and press ok.
And our input range is our returns column
from cell H2.
Control shift down, selects the whole
returns column, and we'll scroll back up
to the top of the spreadsheet, and we want
our output range to be on this
spreadsheet, on this worksheet, so our
descriptive data is on this worksheet, and
so we change the output options to output
range.
And then remember to click off the output
range, and we're going to use cell T2 to
display the descriptive statistics, and
we'll need to make sure that we choose
summary statistics at the bottom to
display our descriptive statistics before
pressing ok.
So this will load a number of summary
statistics of our data, so it's done it
now, we'll just adjust the column widths,
so we can see this data, see these
statistics a bit more easily.
Ok, so let's interpret some of these.
So the mean, this is just the average
daily return of the S&P 500 over the
historical period that we're looking at.
Ok, so this is about 0.03%.
Intuitively we would know it's positive,
because we know the S&P 500 is up since
1962.
The median is the middle number of the
data set, so if I had a data set of 1%,
2%, and 10%, the middle of that data set
would be 2%, the middle number.
So that's the median.
Intuitively, by seeing the median, the
middle number is above the mean, we know
that more values lie above the mean than
below the mean, so the ones below the mean
must be more extreme.
And so we can interpret this as the
negative values being more extreme than
the positive ones.
Ok, so let's continue.
The standard deviation is the next one.
We can just interpret this one as a
measure of the dispersion of the data.
Ok, so in a normal distribution, you might
know that there's roughly 68% of the
frequency of the data lies within one
standard deviation either side of the
mean.
So in this case that would be 1% either
side of the mean.
That's not necessarily true, in fact it
isn't true in our empirical distribution
as we'll see further on.
So just bear in mind it's a measure of our
data's dispersion.
So next we'll look at the kurtosis and
skewness values.
These are just values that help us
understand whether our data is normally
distributed or not.
So the kurtosis value is a measure of how
peaked the data is and how the tails
differ from a normal distribution.
So a normal distribution in terms of how
Excel displays the kurtosis value would
have a value of 0.
So this high kurtosis value basically
means that our data set, our empirical
data set, is more peaky and has higher or
fatter returns in the tails.
Ok, so fatter tails in our data set.
And the skewness value as a minus number
means that basically our fat tail, our
negative fat tail, is bigger than our
positive tail.
Meaning that extreme negative movements
are more likely to occur than extreme
positive movements.
Ok, so the next value we look at is the
range which is just the difference between
the highest daily return that's been in
our data set to the lowest daily return.
And that's split up into the maximum
minimum which are the next two cells.
So we can see that the lowest daily return
is minus 20% which is twice the magnitude
of the largest positive return which is
just 10%.
So again that backs up our idea about
skewness.
Negative extremes are of greater magnitude
than positive extremes.
The sum is just the sum of our entire
returns column.
Effectively it means nothing other than
that.
It's certainly not the return that you
would yield if you held this asset from
1962 to 2012.
And finally the count is the number of
trading days within our data set.
So now we've interpreted our descriptive
statistics a little bit.
Let's display the frequencies of our
ranges in our data in terms of
probabilities so we can interpret them a
bit more easily.
Ok, so in column O let's head this column
with probabilities.
And in O2 we type the formula, sorry in O3
we type the formula for probabilities
which is just the frequency, the number of
days within this range.
So that's M3 divided by the total number
of trading days, that's the count in our
descriptive statistics which is U16.
And that will give us a percentage.
But before we enter this formula into this
cell we're going to press F4 which puts
these dollar signs around the denominator
of the equation when our cursor is on the
denominator.
It fixes the cell that your cursor is
within and when I pressed F4 just then it
fixed the denominator which basically will
allow us to drag down the formula, copy
the formula down to the cells below and it
will just move the numerator down
appropriately but it won't change this
cell, the denominator.
Ok, so if we just press enter and then
select that cell again and drag this
formula down.
And while that's still selected if we
right click within that selection and
format the cells so that their percentages
are displayed as percentages.
Ok, so we can see for example that 5.64%
of our data, of our daily return values
lie within minus 1.5 to minus 1.1%.
Ok, so that we can interpret all these
probabilities like that.
So basically for this first value that
would be 2.23% of our return values lie
lower than minus 2% so less than or equal
to minus 2%.
Another way to understand and interpret
these probabilities a bit more easily is
if we display them in cumulative
probabilities which will allow us to
analyze sections of the data.
So if we head column P, so column P, so
column P, cell P2 and we put cumulative
probabilities, adjust the column width
appropriately.
And this time in the first cell P3 we just
type equal to O3.
In cell P4 we type equal to P3 plus O4 and
then we can copy this formula down in cell
P4 and this will give us our cumulative
probability distribution.
Ok, so what is meaning when we can
interpret this a bit better than our
normal probabilities column is because we
can start saying things like
10.56% of the data lies with the return of
less than minus 1%.
Ok, so 10.5% of the time the S&P 500
yields returns of less than minus 1%.
And you can turn that on its head and say
that 90% of the time the S&P 500 yields a
return of greater than minus 1%.
So you can kind of interpret these how you
like and manipulate it how you like.
Ok, so let's go ahead and tidy the
spreadsheet up a little bit now.
If we just tidy these values up that we've
just been looking at, we'll create borders
around these cells.
So if we select cell L2 down to P12 and
then go to the home tab on the ribbon and
with this range still selected, go to the
borders drop down and select all borders.
That will give borders around those cells
and we'll move the graph to the right hand
side.
So let's zoom out the spreadsheet, move
the graph to the right hand side before we
continue.
So our spreadsheet looks a little better.
Ok, so we've basically done, considered
some basic statistics and got a basic
understanding of how our distribution
works using the tools that Excel has given
us so far.
But what we can do is manipulate this data
further to get a real in-depth
understanding of what's going on.
And we'll do that by filtering the returns
column and then analysing subsets of data.
So before we continue, let's add three
rows to the top of the spreadsheet to
create a little bit more space.
So we just click on row 1 on the left hand
side and right click, click insert, 1, 2
and 3.
And then what we can do is, once we've
filtered these returns, we'll look at the
average of a subset.
So first of all, let's add the filter to
the returns column.
Ok, so we click on cell H4, the top of the
returns column, and go to data, the data
tab on the ribbon, and select filter.
And this is applied drop down arrows to
all the columns here, A to H, which allows
us to filter and sort all these columns by
any of these date, open, high, low,
returns, whatever, any of those.
So for example, we could change all this
data from newest to oldest to oldest in
terms of date.
So that's turned the dates now upside
down.
So now we've got the return, the close,
the open, all of that data for 1962 at the
top.
Ok, so we'll just go and undo that, change
it back to newest to oldest.
So now we know we can filter our returns.
What we'll start by doing is working out
the average of subsets of returns.
So to do that we need to create a cell
that works out the average of this returns
column when it's filtered and sorted and
we've done whatever we want to.
So in cell K2, let's type average return
and adjust the column width.
And in L2, we type the formula to work out
the average return for the subset, which
is subtotal, brackets, one for the
average, comma, the reference values,
which are the returns column, which is now
H5, down to H12807.
And then we close the brackets in the
formula bar up here and press enter.
Ok, and that's given us in L2 the average
return for our entire unfiltered data set,
which you'll notice is obviously the same
as our mean as a data set because average
and mean are the same thing.
It's displayed slightly differently
because of rounding, but they are the same
values.
But what will happen is when we change the
returns column, this average return will
change here, but the mean, the descriptive
statistics, these are all fixed from our
total data set, so these won't change.
Ok, so what might be useful is if we
understand the average positive and
negative returns of our data set.
Ok, so to do that we filter the returns
column, so we click on this filter here,
number filters, and what we're going to do
is go to greater than to filter them.
We put greater than zero and that will
give us only positive returns.
Ok, so that's unfiltered.
Ok, so before we continue actually, let's
just name cell M1 avpos for average
positive return and M2 avneg for average
negative return.
Ok, and as you notice when I filtered
those returns it actually hid a load of
rows because it's taken out all the zeros
and negative return values.
So for example we go from row 5 to 8 and
it's affected the rest of our spreadsheet,
but don't worry, when you clear the filter
in the returns column that will all go
back to normal.
What you also will notice is the average
return in cell L2 has changed to the
average return for all positive returns.
So what we can do, because this keeps
changing to our average return for
whatever we display, whatever we filter,
we'll copy this by right clicking on the
cell, copy, and we'll paste it into N1
representing the average positive return
as a value which is fixed and so won't
change.
And we can do the same for negative, so we
go to number filters in the returns
column, less than zero, ok.
And now we've got the average negative
return in L2, again we're going to copy
that and we're going to paste it as a
value into cell N2.
Ok, so what we can do now is calculate the
number of days that the S&P 500 has been
up and down
and calculate that as a percentage of the
total days that we've got in our data set
as well.
So before we continue, we need to create a
cell that can do a similar thing to this
average return, but just for count, so it
just counts the subset of return data.
Ok, so in, actually before we continue
we'll just unfilter this returns column.
Ok, and then in cell T2 what we'll do is
create a cell called count and then in U2
we'll type in the formula for typing the
count of the subset of returns.
So that will be subtotal, similar to
before, similar to the average return,
brackets 2 this time for count, you can
see that from the drop down menu here.
And then comma, the reference numbers
which are the returns column, so that's
H5, press control shift down, select the
whole returns column, close the brackets,
press enter.
Ok, so that's created the count for our
subset of data, for our unfiltered data
because we removed the filter beforehand.
And we can verify that because it's the
same as our descriptive statistics count
down here.
And this will change when we change our
filter.
So, let's add another column to the top of
the spreadsheet.
And type frequency into cell O1.
And frequency percent into P1.
And then, what we'll do is work out the
number of days that the S&P 500 has been
positive in our data set.
So let's filter the returns again to
positive, number filters, greater than 0.
Ok.
This has changed the count to 6707.
So we just put in that, 6707.
You can copy and paste in with the values
like I did before or just type it because
it's quite easy this time.
Ok.
And the same for negative, so less than
this time.
Less than 0.
Ok.
And this is 6006 days.
So obviously that's going to be missing
some days because there will be some days
that are 0.
So let's count those as well.
So in cell N4, we'll add 0 as a value and
work out the frequency of that by
filtering the returns column to equals 0.
Ok.
And we've got a count of 90.
So we'll just put in 90 in cell O4.
Ok.
So clear the filter from returns.
So as a percentage, to work out the
percentage of a number of days that are
positive, negative and 0.
So for positive in P2, we type equals O2
divided by U20.
So that is the number of positive days in
our dataset divided by the total number of
days.
And we'll fix cell U20 so we can copy down
this formula again.
Ok.
So we can copy this down.
And with this still selected, we'll right
click within the selection format cells
and change that percentage to a percentage
with two decimal places.
Ok.
So we can see now 52% of our days the S&P
500 has yielded positive return, 46.9,
negative and almost or close to 1% it's
flat.
So what we can do now is we're going to
work out the average return if you were to
predict when the S&P 500 is up and you go
long on all those days.
You work out the average daily return that
you'd get over this entire period.
Ok.
So if we type average return and then in
cell Q2 we type equals this average
positive return times by the frequency.
Press enter and we do the same.
We can copy that down to the negative
cell.
So we've got the average negative and
average positive return.
Should you, so I'll explain that a little
better.
So this cell Q2, this refers to the
average positive daily return that you
would get if you predicted all the days
when the S&P 500 would be up and you
invested in those.
And you were flat all the other days in
this entire period.
Your average return per day would be this.
And the same for negative.
Ok.
So let's just change all these to
percentage values now.
So cell N2 and N3 select them.
Format cells.
Right click in the selection.
Change the percentage.
Two decimal places.
And the same for these average returns
here.
So what this is telling us, these average
returns are that even if you predict the
positives and invest in only those days
and go flat the rest of the time or don't
invest the rest of the time, the margins,
the profit margins you work with are still
pretty small.
Ok.
And because we're trading daily and these
are our sort of average returns that we
get daily even if we predicted it right,
they're going to get wiped out by things
like transaction costs.
They're not, it's almost not worth trading
daily when you have this, when you have a
normal amount of volatility.
Ok.
So that's what these values here are
telling us.
The final procedure that we're going to
carry out on this spreadsheet is to find
out how many trading days lie within
different standard deviations of the mean
in our data set.
Ok.
So what we need to do is, in fact first
we'll clear some space on the spreadsheet.
So if we just add another two columns into
the spreadsheet.
And what we're going to do is calculate
the standard deviation returns values for
one, two and three standard deviations
above and below the mean.
Ok.
So in cell W2 type std dev standard
deviation and one, two and three in x,
two, y, two and z, two respectively.
And then upper that represents the one
standard deviation, one, two and three
standard deviations above the mean.
And then another row lower for one, two
and three standard deviations below the
mean.
So that was in cell W3 and cell W4.
Ok.
So to work out these values, these return
values, what we do, in cell X3 we'll type
equals the mean.
Ok.
So we always start with the mean.
And then for one standard deviation above
the mean, because we're in the upper
bound, we just plus the standard
deviation.
Ok.
And for the lower bound, we start with the
mean and we minus one standard deviation.
Ok.
In the next column, we're applying that
method to two standard deviations.
So we start with the mean and we add two
times the standard deviation.
And for the lower bound, we start with the
mean and we minus two times the standard
deviation.
And the same for the last column.
So equals the mean plus three times the
standard deviation.
And the mean minus three times the
Okay.
So now we've got the returns values that
represent one, two and three standard
deviations above and below the mean.
So for now, we're going to keep these as
decimal displays because we need to input
them into our return filters.
Sorry.
Return filters over here in a minute.
Okay.
So we're going to find how many trading
days lie between yield returns between
these values.
Okay.
So we'll find out how many trading days in
our empirical distribution lie between
roughly that's plus one percent and minus
one percent, which is one standard
deviation.
And then we'll do the same for two
standard deviations and three standard
deviations.
And we'll compare it to how many days a
normal distribution would give us with
those standard deviations.
Okay.
So in AB2, cell AB2, we'll type standard
deviation again.
And this time one, two and three going
down the column.
And then we type actual.
So this will be that column for the actual
number of days in our empirical
distribution that lie between these bounds
for one, two and three standard
deviations.
Okay.
And we'll compare that to what a normal
distribution would be.
And then we'll compare the percentage of
these values as well.
Okay.
So that's AC3 is actual, AD3 normal, AE3
actual percent, and AF3 normal percent.
So let's filter our returns column.
I'm just going to zoom out the spreadsheet
a little bit.
Filter our returns column between these
standard deviation returns values.
So if we click the filter on the returns
column and we go to between, we want to
give returns that are greater than or
equal to our lower bound for one standard
deviation.
So that's this value here.
So we can type in minus 0.00972 and less
than our upper bound, which is 0.01031.
Press okay.
Filter that.
We see we've got 10,062 days that lie
within those values.
So we just input that into cell AC3,
10,062.
Okay.
And we do the same for the two standard
deviations.
So filter between.
This time we're using these upper and
lower bounds.
So below, sorry, greater than 0.01974 and
less than 0.02032.
Filter.
So that's 12,208.
You can see that in cell U5.
That's the count that changes with our
subset of returns.
So 12,208.
And we'll do the same for the three
standard deviations.
Minus 0.02975 and 0.03033.
So we put that in here.
Okay.
So let's go to the normal distribution
now.
And we're going to start from what we know
about our normal distribution is we know
the
percent of the frequencies, the percentage
trading days that should lie between one
standard deviation
from the mean and two and three.
Okay.
So in a normal distribution, 68.2 percent
of trading days will lie within one
standard deviation
from the mean.
95.4 percent of trading days will lie
within two standard deviations from the
mean in terms
of their returns.
And within three standard deviations from
the mean, 99.8 percent of trading days
will occur.
Okay.
So let's fill out the actual number of
days given our total count.
12,803 days in our data set.
We can work out the normal number of days
that is the number of days predicted by a
normal distribution
that would lie within one, two and three
standard deviations.
So that's just in AD3 we type equals the
percent that would lie within one standard
deviation times the count.
And we'll fix the count cell.
Press F4 around U22.
And then we can apply this down.
And we can see that we've got 12,777 days
that a normal distribution predicts will
lie within three standard deviations from
the mean.
Okay.
Given a data set of 12,803 days.
So let's just convert these actual days to
percent as well.
So this is the actual number of days
within each standard deviation from the
mean divided by the count.
Okay.
So AC3 divided by the count.
We'll fix this cell again as a reference
so we can copy it down.
Copy this down.
And with that still selected we'll format
these cells as well.
I'll display them in a percentage.
Okay.
So.
I think before we interpret these last
results let's select the cells X3 to Z4
and change all these standard deviations
to in terms of percent as well.
With two decimal places is fine.
Right.
So.
Let's do these first.
Our standard deviations.
One standard deviation from the mean
represents roughly an upper bound of one
percent and a lower bound of minus one
percent.
Okay.
Which means two standard deviations will
be roughly that.
Roughly two.
Times that.
And three.
Three times that.
So.
In terms of where these standard deviation
values lie on this histogram.
We're looking at an upper bound of one
percent and a lower bound of minus one
percent.
So we're looking at from this bar here to
this bar here is one standard deviation.
Okay.
Which in our empirical distribution
accounts for almost 80 percent of our
data.
Whereas in a normal distribution it's
something like 60, 68, ten percent lower.
This means that our empirical distribution
there's many more trading days that lie
closer to the mean.
Okay.
Which is close to zero as well.
We should point out it's close to zero.
So that means our distribution is more
peaked.
Which is predicted by our kurtosis value
that we discussed earlier.
It's more peaked than a normal
distribution.
Okay.
And as we go further out and we look at
the standard deviations that are deeper
into the tails of the distribution.
We can see that instead of our empirical
distribution accounting for more than the
normal distribution.
It starts accounting for less.
By the time we get to three standard
deviations our empirical distribution
accounts for 98.7.
Whereas the normal distribution accounts
for a percent more.
As you go further and further out this
difference will be more significant.
So basically what we're saying is our
empirical asset distributions tend to have
fatter tails.
More extreme movements than predicted by
normality.
Okay.
So what does this all mean?
So two key things.
Okay.
First thing.
The fact that 80% of the time the S&P
barely moves makes it a lot harder to
generate returns.
Okay.
Especially when you account for
transaction costs.
It means that our opportunities are
minimal when we're looking at daily
trading.
Especially when the volatility's are low.
Okay.
And that's given by these average returns
that we looked at over here as well.
The second thing is.
Just something to be aware of.
Is that by analyzing this distribution of
returns we can understand that there are
greater risks in the tails.
In the extremities of the distribution.
So they're actually more probable than you
might think.
Okay.
So that means there are likely to be days
when you'd be wiped out of your position.
Of your account.
Okay.
So roughly one in a hundred days we've got
a fairly significant move of more than 3%.
Which could wipe you out if you've got the
position on the wrong way.
Okay.
So they're the two major things.
So the key thing we need to understand is
that this basically implies that
opportunities are minimal when there's low
volatility.
The other thing just to keep in the back
of your mind is that there is greater risk
than predicted by normal distributions.
And we should also point out that this
spreadsheet, you can apply this method to
any asset over any period, any frequency.
So one week, like weekly, monthly, yearly
data.